a lot of people have been talking about
the newest member of Donald Trump's
legal team Jay Sekulow over the weekend
he appeared on all the political shows
to reiterate that President Trump is not
not under investigation but he ran into
trouble during this Fox News interview
where he seemed to contradict himself so
he's being investigated for taking the
action that the Attorney General Deputy
Attorney General recommended him to take
by the agency who recommended the
termination you've now said that he is
getting investigated after saying that
you didn't know you you just said you
just said that he's being investigated
yeah well that clip that clip has gone
viral everyone's talking about it and
you know it's also come out and this is
true this is Reard that Trump hired
Sekulow after seeing him on Fox News
yeah he's some on Fox News yeah
apparently the president saw mr. sakulos
ad and was impressed
we actually got a hold of the ad that
Trump saw that inspired him take a look
hello were you recently involved in a
hit-and-run did you find a mouse in your
fast-food hamburger or are you the
President of the United States currently
entangled in a special council
investigation that has the potential to
shape the very foundations of our
democracy then call me me attorney Jay
Sekulow
I'm a real straight shooter to wrangle
up a heaping helping of justice let's
giddyup to court I'll get you off five
[Applause]
you